you
welcome to this press conference where
we will present this year's Nobel Prize
in Chemistry we will start in Swedish
and then continue the presentation in
English and as I always say each year
you have free to post your questions in
either language yo yo here d'stefano
backyard and the Secretary had become
gravitons cops Academy me ma heart for
so Konoha semester the Herger professors
vanilla bean and wood for and a Nobel
Committee and Fushimi or some oxygen
swap a few occuring comedians please
salvia
what against Roma professor Soros no
group Lynne's Lea de Mouton Nobel
Committee on Fushimi some Strax Cabrillo
Tamara on preset orit's priests billion
our sin Rica Muto Guerra Pasolini's EDA
ganglia vs cops Academy in hobbies live
nativity a lot photos and tall vash
noble precision metal
professor Robert Yi levkovets with
Howard Hughes Medical Institute or Duke
University Medical Center Durham North
Carolina
you saw pork Professor Brian kobilka
with Stanford University School of
Medicine
Stamford Californian you saw academia
smote appearing leader first ilya of
gear protein cobbler recipe tubular this
year's price deals with cells and
Sensibility the Royal Swedish Academy of
Sciences has decided to award the 2012
Nobel Prize in Chemistry to Professor
Robert J Lefkowitz at how to use Medical
Institute and Duke University Medical
Center Durham North Carolina
you saw and Professor Brian K kobilka
at Stanford University School of
Medicine Stanford California USA and the
Academy citation runs
for studies of g-protein coupled
receptors professors Finley Dean will
now give us a short summary in English
please then thank you Stefan
do you remember the last time you got
really scared the dryness of the mouth
the heart that skips a beat these are
signs that your body is getting ready
for flight or fight adrenaline surges
through the system and it effects
metabolism circulation respiration
muscle tonus and vision it leads to an
orchestrated response from the billions
of individual cells that make up our
bodies it was known for a long time that
adrenaline does not enter into the cells
it effects but an increase in the
adrenaline levels on the outside of the
cell leads to a response at the inside a
receptive substance a receptor was
correctly assumed to be involved but the
nature of this receptor and how it acted
remained a mystery for a long time now
thanks to the work of Robert Lefkowitz
and Brian kobilka awarded this year's
Nobel Prize in Chemistry we know what
this receptor looks like in the finest
molecular detail we also know that it's
just one member of a huge family of
receptors the g-protein coupled
receptors or the GPCRs we know the
mechanism by which GPCRs function and we
know how that function is regulated
now the communication between our cells
is essential not only in times of fear
but in everyday life and unbalance in
this communication leads to unhealth now
a large proportion some say 50% of all
pharmaceuticals used today rely on
action targeting GPCRs so knowing what
they look like and how
function will provide us with the tools
that can help us to make better drugs
with fewer side-effects
thank you for these words professor Lee
Dean and now professor snow grappling
sir you will give a more detailed
presentation of this year's price Thank
You
g-protein coupled receptors sit in the
membrane they tell the inside of the
cell what's going on on the outside
thanks to the studies by Robert
Lefkowitz and Brian kobilka we know how
these receptors are built how they work
and how they are regulated there's a
whole family of receptors that are built
in a very similar way they all have
seven the heel assists spiral light
structures here depicted at Watts Watts
that go through the membrane therefore
they are also called seven transmembrane
receptors 70m in our body circulates a
number of neurotransmitters and hormones
some of the names you may recognize
serotonin histamine adrenaline etc and
these action via g-protein coupled
receptors the molecule to the left
adrenalin binds to at least nine
different g-protein coupled receptors in
our bodies and cause different responses
in different organs so when the heart
and lungs muscles are activated at the
same time our digestion is shut down the
molecule to the right is man-made it's a
beta blocker it's similar to adrenaline
yet different enough that it only binds
to subsets of the adrenaline receptors
therefore it only affects certain organs
indeed the g-protein coupled receptors
are the targets for about half of all
form a suitable drugs made today and
these are used in treatment or
conditions like high blood pressure new
of psychiatric disorders Parkinson's
disease migraine gastric disorder
you name it think of a decease and there
is probably a medicine there affecting a
give protein-coupled receptor so the
receptor sits in the membrane and when a
signal comes here in the form of
increased adrenaline concentration the
task for this receptor is now to tell
the inside of the cell that this has
happened but it doesn't do so by letting
adrenaline in you can see no adrenaline
inside the cell
instead they receptor binds each
receptor binds one molecule of
adrenaline in a pocket on the outside
region and this leads to a change in the
shape of the receptor so that it opens
up the site in the inside where it can
bind another protein for example a
g-protein here it's depicted in red with
alpha beta and gamma subunits the
receptor is a little bit like a bundle
of wards when the receptor is not
activated the wards are fairly parallel
to one another
and on the inside of the cell there's
really nothing to interact with when a
small molecule binds at the outside what
are small changes in the structure here
propagates into much larger change on
the inside for the g-protein combined
this is also the reason another small
molecule can elicit very different
changes on the inside which then signals
through other proteins on the inside and
other signaling pathways the complex we
see here is the active signaling unit it
is sometimes called the ternary complex
because free things are needed to come
together the hormone the receptor and
the g-protein this has been known since
the middle of the 1980s thanks to
studies using for example radioactive
hormones cloning work today we know what
this complex looks like in near atomic
detail
what you see here is a molecular
masterpiece is the result of three
decades of dedicated biochemical work at
the bench the met is derived to be able
to obtain this structure by
crystallography have now also been used
and are being currently used to make
crystals of a large number of drug
important receptors to divider
structures the receptor in the membrane
is something like a switchboard in the
wall of a building the operator of the
switchboard speaks more than one
language
therefore clients of different
nationality can call the same
switchboard but the operator is
experienced enough to send a signal in
different directions
depending on who calls this is exactly
like a deep protein coupled receptor
depending on what small molecule binds
to the outside the signal is sent in
different directions inside the cell
this is very important knowledge in
development of drugs to obtain
medications with fewer side-effects each
operator speaks only a limited set of
languages therefore a number of switch
ports are needed to serve all the
clients in the world we have about 1,000
different g-protein coupled receptors in
our body to be able to sense a huge
number or different hormones
neurotransmitters and other signals some
clients can call more than one
switchboard in our body adrenaline can
interact with nine different receptors
and cause very different responses in
different locations g-protein coupled
receptors are also found on the outside
our body in the sensory cells in our
nose on our tongue in our eyes and this
allows us to sense our environment to
smell to taste and see and how in you
really need a cup of coffee thank
thank you thanks to the g-protein
coupled receptors I cannot really enjoy
this cup of coffee the smell the aroma
the beautiful serving neurotransmitters
hormones many g-protein coupled
receptors are active now and thanks to
the studies by Robert Lefkowitz and
Brian kobilka I can also enjoy the
excitement of knowing exactly in finest
molecular detail what's going on in my
body right now when many signals are
passed over my cell membranes thank you
Thank You professor snuggerud Lindsay
and people now see if we can get a hold
of one of the two laureates and do we
have professor levkovets there with us
on the phone okay congratulations again
I know it's it's six o'clock and and the
professor's no goblins has already got
her coffee I hope you have got the same
and congratulations and I tell you that
we are sitting in the session hole here
in Stockholm at the Royal Swedish
Academy of Sciences and we have around
1890 a persons from Swedish and
international press and I know that they
are eager to pull some questions to you
are you ready to to take on these
questions professor lipcott yeah okay so
please go ahead
my name is Victoria Dearing I'm from the
Swedish television we are live on air
right now
first congratulations how are you
feeling right now I'm feeling very very
excited could you tell us how did you
get this message well I was fast asleep
and the phone rang I did not hear it I
must share with you that I where he
plugs sleep and so my wife gave me an
elbow fall for you and there was a total
shock and surprise as many before me
have have experienced have you told
anyone yet through no app you're
familiar with Skype
I just before the conference started
guys Rock
it was after the started I got I Bilka
the other winner and someone I speak to
very often up calling to congratulate
but I could take off about it so as yet
we've told nobody okay have you any
plans for today well I I'm thinking that
this is going to be a very very hectic
day I plan to go to the office I was
going to get a haircut but which if you
could see me you would see is quite a
necessity but I'm afraid that will
probably have to be postponed it'll be a
pretty crazy day at my office as I think
I think you'll have to cope with that
long hair today one more day have you
been to Stockholm before I have been on
any a case for scientific conferences
and lectures and will you be coming to
Stockholm in December yeah I will be
coming indeed with with my wife Lynn and
with his I have a large family I have
five children and five grandchildren so
I'm sure they won't all be able to come
but those ghetto or I'm hope some of the
family will come we look forward to that
congratulations again thank you very
much do we have some other questions
we have a question there and I have a
question about these receptors we were
told not just now that they are the
targets of about half of the
pharmaceuticals that the drug industry
make what about them make them so useful
in in medicine well I think there are
several things so you in medicine the
first is that as you probably heard
there are very lot of these receptors
and they they serve as the Gateway to
the cells or many neurotransmitters and
form a body as a result they are
crucially positioned to regulate almost
every known physiological process in
humans and of course as physicians what
we need to do in cases of disease is to
manipulate the activity of these normal
substance like adrenaline your serotonin
dopamine the diversity of of substances
in our body that work through this
mechanism that makes them so crucially
positioned to be able to respond to
drugs of various types we have a
question there hi and congratulations
professor Lefkowitz my name is Louise
I'm from The Associated Press I'm gonna
ask you a very very typical question
that we always get when the prices are
announced did you expect to win this
price and or not just tell me a little
bit about if you've been anticipating it
or not in fact that's a wonderful
question let me let me start with the
short term in the long term in terms of
the short term I was just commenting a
few minutes ago about the fact that if
if the committee has any questions about
the
the extent to which their secrecy works
let me say it does it did not have a
single rumor or inclination or clue of
any kind that's it so I can assure you I
did not go to sleep last night waiting
for this call
so that's portent one for the longer
term sure I think every scientist needs
a little recess of his mind that someday
one would get a call like that but it's
more fantasy than anything else so did I
expect to get it
no did I even have any inkling that it
was coming I would have to say no okay
thank you very much I think this was
actually the the last question for f4u
and and from from the press professor
Lefkowitz thank you very much for being
with us here live on the line and and we
once again give you our warmest
congratulations and we look forward to
meet you in Stockholm in December for
the Nobel Prize ceremony so thanks again
bye so let's move on yeah are there any
more questions from the press about the
chemistry prize and the research
involved and you can as I said give
questions in either Swedish or English
if not a it's time for me to end this
press conference thank you for your
attention and we hope to see you back on
Monday the 15th when we will announce
this very slick spanks Prize in Economic
Sciences and memory of Alfred Nobel
thank you very much thank you
you